on va parler de photographie pour les
amateurs entre photographie et un
rendez-vous qui se tient à Villepreux
qui est proposé par Villepreux images
pixel c'est du 14 au 22 janvier à la
maison à Saint-Vincent-de-Paul plus
d'une vingtaine de photographes se
présente leurs clichés pour cette expo
photo on le disait en début d'émission
il y a Gilles fake qui est avec nous qui
est photographe également responsable
communication de Villepreux images
pixels on va voir pendant l'entretien
quelques-unes des photographies qui
seront exposées s'afficher combien de
photographes participent à cette
exposition alors on est environ 25
photographes et donc on a limité à 3 3 4
photos par photographe qui représente
environ 80 plus de 80 photos parce que
des petits formats et des grands formats
on a une très belle série par exemple
sur des singes dans nos photographes
Michel voilà et puis on a vraiment le
thème cette année était libre puisque
comme vous le savez pendant deux ans on
a été un petit peu en somnolence avec le
covid ça vous a pas mal impacté au
niveau de l'association alors au niveau
de l'association oui parce que malgré
tout on a perdu des adhérents c'est vrai
comment on a toujours gardé ce lien
puisqu'on travaillait en visioconférence
mais parler de photos en visioconférence
vous savez quand les gens ont fait du
télétravail ils ont fait de la vision
qu'on fait retour arriver chez eux
refaire voilà une téléconférence sur sur
la photo c'est que c'était compliqué et
nous on est un club d'échange et la
passion et puis la photo faut qu'elle
soit imprimée faut qu'elle soit vue on
touche voilà donc c'est vrai que c'est
un petit peu un petit peu tombé en
sommeil mais on redémarre si certains
veulent venir
adhérer aux villes premier match pixel
bien sûr on a on les accueille avec
grand plaisir mais oui on a eu une
petite baisse de d'adhérents mais bon la
qualité est là c'est le principal alors
ça y est on les voit c'est assez photo
s'afficher alors qui sont c'est
justement ces artistes qui sont exposés
est-ce que on parle d'animateurs
confirmé de professionnels est-ce que
c'est tout simplement sont tout
simplement des membres de l'association
alors au niveau du club on se sent tous
des passionnés puisque on n'est pas une
école de photographie bien sûr on va
apprendre aux gens à servir à
s'améliorer mais avant tout ils se sont
photographe et ben c'est comme dans
toute comme dans toute discipline on a
des très bons on a du Mbappe si j'ose
dire on a du Griezmann voilà pour
prendre des références mais voilà ce
sont tous des passionnés certains ont
pardon on a du regret aussi
bon là je note non non voilà on forme
les biens sur les photographes mais je
dirais que le fait d'être adhérent aux
villes primage on se forme s'auto forme
et on s'améliore d'aller en année à vous
le savez moi ça fait très longtemps que
je fais de la photo je prends mon
exemple mais c'est vraiment quand je
suis rentré en 2007 dans dans ce club où
j'ai progressé au contact de photographe
puisque en plus nous on a un cheval de
bataille c'est à dire en étant loin
c'est que le vendredi on analyse des
photos de façon anonyme c'est-à-dire on
projette une photo d'un auteur de d'un
photographe et on lui dit les points
améliorés les points qui vont bien donc
à force de regarder ça de de d'écouter
ces critiques positives ou négatives on
s'améliore voilà donc ce sont tous des
photographes aguerris malgré tout mais
on prend vraiment tout le monde on a on
a on vient de recevoir encore trois
nouveaux récemment ils vont exposer et
bien sûr ils sont les bienvenus voilà
toutes les photos sont les bienvenues et
comment vous les sélectionner justement
les photos qui qui sont montrées lors de
cette exposition alors dans un premier
temps détermine thème donc cette année
comme son savais pas si ça allait avoir
lieu cette exposition on a fait un thème
libre donc ça veut dire que déjà les
photographes ont quand même une
bibliothèque chez eux de photos ils
choisissent ben des clichés soit une
série pas forcément une série de
l'architecture des animaux il y en a qui
font des voyages là on est parti aussi
avec le club faire une série à la à la
défense sur l'architecture et puis s'ils
hésitent sur des sur certaines photos et
bien on les aide à faire le choix voilà
est-ce que cette année il y en a une
peut-être qui a retenu un peu plus votre
attention une préférée ou c'est toujours
délicat parce que comme je vais
retourner dans le club quand même
prochainement voilà non non chaque vous
savez le principal c'est que le
photographe aime sa photo et après vous
aurez toujours des gens qui ont aimé et
d'autres qui n'ont pas aimé c'est bon
voilà non non il y a pas vraiment de
photos pour l'instant qui qui
va aller on va dire de de 20 euros
jusqu'à 120 euros 150 euros et on a
toute une collection d'anciennes photos
qui ont fait des concours qui seront
pour faire plaisir aux gens on les met à
la vente je crois que c'est 5 euros vous
pouvez venir me faire plaisir avec une
photo dans une Mary Louise très sympa et
toutes les informations qui s'affichent
de nouveau ce qu'il y a d'autres
rendez-vous prévu dans l'année vous
l'avez dit après le covid ça reprend
alors ça reprend on a quand même comme
vous le savez on a été le premier club a
créé le festival de la photo panoramique
en 2014 j'étais venu d'ailleurs ici en
parler on le faisait tous les deux ans
parce que c'est vraiment très lourd on
se pose la question de savoir si on va
le faire en 2024
donc voilà ça c'est un projet et puis
sinon on a un projet qu'on voudrait
relancer avec justement l'atelier studio
photo c'est les villes prosiens et leurs
animaux donc on l'avait déjà fait et on
exposera on l'espère on demandera bien
sûr au merde d'exposer dans la mairie ou
les villes prosiens viennent avec alors
c'était super parce que ils sont venus
avec des lapins des des chats bien sûr
des chiens des on avait un très beau
perroquet enfin voilà on a eu des
toutes les informations à propos de
cette exposition merci j'ai fait merci
beaucoup merci beaucoup